hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now it is
finally time to do what must be done
it is a brand new day and it is a brand
new dawn and with that comes a new game
I'm not looking forward to this
experience and I know you guys weren't
either in the past I've told you guys
that I have kept this save game for
months
the same game I have been building on
for months many multitudes of hours
poured into one game and I've upgraded
over and over throughout every update
that's come out hoping and praying that
it would not blow up my game and yet
with the most recent update the
machinery update I can no longer keep my
old game I would be missing out on too
much of the environment that they've
built in since those updates came out so
with that said I am going into this new
game without any console commands I will
not be cheating because in the end of
the day cheating kind of cheapens the
experience of the entire game and it'll
just ruin it for me and it'll ruin the
fun for everybody so I'm going to be
diving back into this ocean something
something symbolic ISM about how this is
gonna be blah blah blah here we go
live so welcome back now with this
update there's been a quite a number of
things released number one I just
realized how defenseless I am I don't
even have a knife I don't have a bubble
but I don't have my seamoth I don't have
the [ __ ] duck I don't have the [ __ ] of
the ocean I don't even have Charon on my
side well I mean I've got Karen Karen's
always gonna be there for me literally I
have no one but Karen keeping me company
at night her cold metal endoskeleton
pressed up against never mind so as with
most okay he totally forgot oh my god I
don't have an air tank I have no oxygen
oh my god so you guys don't need to
worry too much I'm not gonna go through
the meticulous process of starting
completely from scratch I just wanted to
start here so that you guys knew what my
intentions were and why I didn't seem to
be in the same place that I was don't
worry I'm not gonna make you watch me
meticulously pore through everything
Karen I am talking about the Aurora oh
yes we'll go watch the explosion I know
eat something Oh God
uh so many problems oh there's so many
problems I forgot I took it all for
granted but you don't regret it
I lost lonely oh [ __ ] again there's
monsters I really want to kill me oh no
it's getting night - oh god I can't even
chase these fish down I never thought
that I would lose any of the amazing
things that I had built the monuments
that I had stood upon even though some
of them of course I use cheats to get
that besides point ignore ignore that
you don't criticize me I I know I'm bad
this is gonna commemorate the start of
the new game cuz man is this a big deal
okay so now I'm going to get busy I need
to build a habitat my first goal here is
to build a habitat and build the new
mapping room because that does exist
that is one of the new things that I
don't know if I need to find something
to get that goddammit
I have a scanner [ __ ] okay but one step
at a time
building a habitat is literally my
number one priority so I will be back as
soon as that is done welcome to the
party everybody it's gonna be a fun time
I don't know if it's better or worse
that I know what's in the ocean because
I know there are monsters in the ocean
now and eventually I want to get down to
the Lost River which is um this new area
that they're working on it's not fully
implemented apparently but it will be
soon and in there there are monsters the
likes of which you have never seen Wow I
don't know how I survived that but I did
oh god no oh God hahaha it's fine it's
fine it's other person why oh shut up
Karen I feel like a naked baby that was
dumped in the ocean I have nothing to
protect me
I've got nothing nothing I'm alone and
scared oh yeah I always have to be night
god damn it I always do this at night
another cool feature that they added
that was very much needed was the
ability for creatures to respawn after
they've been eaten which they didn't do
before I was not even 100% sure about
that but they
definitely did not respawn before so now
I can eat to my heart's content without
worrying about destroying the entire
ecosystem oh and thank the Lord it's
daytime huh finally which is good at all
[ __ ] right oh it's dead I can't read
fast ah [ __ ] yeah
a tuition so much ooh can I make this
can I'm oh I can make a sea glide
already thank you so much progress take
so much better than I did the first time
I was here good golly with that dare all
right so that's there but that there
scanner their habitat builder there it's
like I never left
it's like it's like my family never left
me in the horrible explosion that I
watched and celebrated it's like none of
my friends died but oh yeah look at that
yeah don't look where you're going just
look at that okay bioreactor perfect all
right that's one of the it's not new
it's been around but that's definitely
cool because now I can use that mobile
vehicle bail so good get my boys back
okay it's time to go time to go it's
time to leave the nest already oh
okay I'm going to I'm gonna try to make
my base in a relatively new location
than where I was whereas my other base
was on the ship side of the kelp forest
I'm gonna try to do this on the far side
of the kelp forest more towards the
couch zone because that'll put me in a
better position for where I need to be
in the future and it'll create a little
difference it would be nice
the problem is I don't want to leave the
safety of the safe zone one because it's
a resource Haven like these safe zones
are actually very very important for me
to be nearby so this is the the southern
safe zone by the kelp forest which is a
place that I've scoured before but I
also want to be at the cusp of a safe
zone a kelp forest and this area to the
south which is a little more interesting
this is about where I want it to be
branching off into the depth of nothing
yeah I think this is exactly where I
want it to be I'll make it in the cusp
of this like this alcove here this will
be like my little my little I'll make it
over here it's a little easier for me to
get to now I like this kind of my home
away from home the the under home is
what I'll call it I won't call it day
I'm not gonna I'm actually I regret
calling it that at all it's that's too
such a stupid name
yes it's beautiful bizarre I made it I
did it yeah I forgot to make class God
all God in its night hmm
and my see Glide ran out of batteries
here we go again back into the ocean
hope I'm going the right way don't know
if that is true I'm really [ __ ] if I'm
going wrong it's gonna be bad if I go
into the dark Oh God you know you know
the Megalodon um
the giant shark from way pre we hope
from way prehistoric era whenever I go
blindly into the darkness I can't help
but think that I'm going to be swimming
along and then I'm just gonna see teeth
and that's gonna be the end of me like
this the kids it's possible
emotion so much
oh good just in time for day I'm glad I
made that round trip in the night boy
ELLs fun
oh there's no power in your [ __ ] oh it's
gonna make it yes I can't all right here
we go one lonely solar panel cuz
hopefully after this I'm gonna have a
bioreactor which I think I actually have
the blueprints for or at least it's
nearby which is nice I'll take this is
that lithium
hot damn thanks Karen boy it's good to
hear your voice again
okay ah oh my god I don't know what it
is about this game that makes me so
stressed something bad the ocean why
can't I make up where's a fabric
keywords if I there it is I was about
say I was gonna be like where I made god
damn sure I had that in line it better
not [ __ ] with me okay there we
I'm a fabricator we don't have a lot of
power admittedly but at least I have a
fabricator here with which that I can
start building from the bottom of the
ocean and just as one new thing from
this before I do anything else I want to
go get the other blueprint for the
bioreactor and I'm going to build that
there we go bioreactor thousand huh okay
I've unlocked the bioreactor soon let's
see what we need further bioreactor I do
new oh I said I had Lube
I had Lube what happened to my lube
Quaker Steak & Lube Lube Papa Trek I
think he was right on time right I first
saw her I've ever had I think I was him
oh I have that I have that in here I put
it in here for storage Boinky Boinky
Boinky and bought it oh it's right in
the center hot tits I rotate that
apparently not this is one of the new
things it's not new but it's it's
working now apparently cool cool oh okay
so all I need to do I put biological
material in here fish and stuff which is
awfully mean but if I just put these in
here it will grind them into fine powder
and then convert it into power how about
that it'll even work at night which is
something that I haven't had for a while
so goody goody gumdrops whoa oh I'm
close
ooh I'm close to a umm I'm close to a
piece of the Aurora I didn't even know I
was this close to one
I bet that that oh no modification what
was that oh I forgot about you huh
Oh God okay you know what forget that
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] everything just watch
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man
Oh God about a battery's [ __ ] my life ha
ha alright guys guess who's back it is
my family the only family I've ever
known if the crack of dawn it's my boys
and they take now they're gonna pop out
this buzzer be more climactic than this
but hang on Disick
um where are they there they are
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall
Marshall was almost not there for a
second Geoffrey Billy Sam wasn't
Marshall how have you been I know I know
holy crap why is this no working uh I
was under the assumption that there was
supposed to be a menu popping up at any
moment there boink um
wait just as it may be because I have
absolutely no blueprints for it and I
can't even make the CMOS and I don't
have that yet but I'll give that but the
most important thing is it's a brand new
day
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall are
back and I've made a lot of progress
I've been playing for about an hour and
a half here but I've been doing okay
getting by we're gonna get there in the
next episode I will be much farther
along I will explore much more things
and I will be ready to build a cyclops
not just a seamoth I'm gonna get the
seamoth and then I'm gonna build a
cyclops for you at the start of the next
episode have lockers for names
thank you everybody so much for watching
it's a brand new game which means brand
new possibilities and will be ready for
new updates the ocean is a terrifying
place don't go so thank you everybody
again and as always I will see you in
the next video I had to use I had to
carve my own sword out of my baby tooth
and I used that as a club because I was
too stupid actually usually like a sword